the whole period of of the the american
revolution and the establishment of the
country of the government it can get
very muddled in people's minds and what
i was hoping we could cover in this
video is kind of unmuddle that kind of
separate out the events and see how they
all fit together well you know let's
start in 1775 because that's when the
rebellion really begins that's when you
have the battles of lexington and
concord and paul revere writing to say
that the british are coming and they've
started to rebel against the taxes that
parliament has put on us they're not
quite clear what the rebellion is all
about especially those people who aren't
up there in massachusetts where the
rebels are happening but by 1776 that's
when they write the declaration that
says here's what we're doing we're
fighting a war of independence and let
facts be submitted to a candid world
here's why we're doing it
and then you get you know you're
fighting the war it's really not until
that we win the war
and around that period between 1776 and
1781 they've drafted this thing called
the articles of confederation
and it's sort of rules by which the
states are going to get together and
sort of govern themselves but it doesn't
really create
a new nation it's really just a
federation of the separate states and
this is really around this idea
all the declaration of independence is
really look we're already essentially at
war this is why this is articulating why
we're at war what we actually believe in
but that didn't establish a government
it didn't actually talk about what kind
of government it would be how it would
govern itself so the articles were
really this for this first attempt at
saying well assuming that we were able
to win this war of independence
how do we set up right and what they
were doing this war of independence were
13 separate states they didn't really
think of themselves as one new nation
some people did ben franklin and others
thought we should really you know be a
union of one nation but when they get
together to do the articles of
confederation really starting right
after the declaration is signed in 1776
they finished writing it in 1777
they write a pretty uninspiring document
that just sort of says we're from a
whole lot of separate states and we're
going to get together a bit
and be a union of these states but we're
not going to give ourselves many powers
as one government yeah we have it right
here i actually had never seen it before
this conversation i've obviously read
about it when i was in history class but
to who to all to whom these presence
shall come we the undersigned delegates
of the states affixed to our names send
greetings oh i mean it's like something
written by a bad template you know out
of a com
movement
so it's not an inspiring document and it
gives no power to a central government
as you say it's the delegates of the
states they affix our names to this and
it's the articles of confederation
perpetual union between these states
one of the main things they
failed to do is give the central
government any taxation power and so
really it's up to the states to tax and
then this congress that's meeting based
on the articles of confederation tries
to beg each one of the states hey
requisition us a little bit of money so
we can continue our business so so the
the federal the central government does
not directly there's no federal income
tax or not any tax of any kind not even
any kind of tax the states can tax in
whatever way they see fit and then they
have to kind of give something what's
kind of amusing is uh we win the
revolution in the battle of yorktown
that's in 1781 and a messenger comes
riding into new york where this congress
has been meeting it sort of floats from
city to city
and gives them all the details and they
don't even have enough money to pay the
messenger they have to reach in their
pockets to do it so you have this sort
of poorly written document called the
articles of confederation that seems to
make a confederation of states meaning
we're going to gather together but we're
going to have our own separate powers
and doesn't give any taxation powers so
you have a kind of messy governance
structure
it's obviously not a perfect analogy but
if we if we take an analogy to present
dates it's kind of what's happening in
europe where there's these separate
nations separate states that are trying
to form some type of union not clear who
has what power the central european
union is
not
directly
taxing
precisely i mean that's a very good
analogy to what was happening because
they weren't quite clear whether they
had a central currency or not back then
they weren't quite sure what are the
powers of each of the states versus the
central government and that's been
something throughout history i mean even
starting with the greek city-states
where you can have confederations and
it's unclear how much power you're going
to put in the central government versus
how much power you're going to leave at
the states and
considering that this is not the
governing document for us now something
must have broken to to want to replace
it well yes by you know by the time
you're getting into 1786
it is totally clear that this document
isn't working you have all sorts of
disputes like maryland virginia are
having this horrible dispute over
navigation and border rights and so they
call an annapolis convention to try to
uh fix that up and they try to get the
states to come only five of them come
you have something up in massachusetts
called shea's rebellion where there was
this rebellion of the poor farmers in
western massachusetts under a former
revolutionary war officer named daniel
shays and it's sort of unclear what his
name was shays yeah s-h-a-y-s just like
you have it yeah
well no the pastor is after yeah daniel
shays was his name and he leaves a
rebellion
and there's no central government to
send a force to stop them i mean
washington's army has been disbanded and
so the poor people of massachusetts have
to try to raise a militia to try to stop
shay's rebellion but they can't get the
federal government to step in and it was
just one of many many symptoms
that we were all disintegrating and
falling apart and there was no sort of
rule of law that governed all the
colonies and now all the states and uh
so what happens is people like hamilton
madison
others get together and say you know
what congress is meeting i think they
were meeting in new york by then we
ought to go back to philadelphia
go back to philadelphia where this all
began in 1776 with the declaration of
independence and we should have a
constitutional convention
we should write a whole new constitution
to govern
centrally this new nation
most of the states agreed to come some
of them worried about the fact that we
were writing a whole new constitution
and so they did not give their delegates
authority to get rid of the articles of
confederation so when they began in that
very hot summer of 1787
it was kind of unclear whether they were
going to be able to write a new
constitution or just try to amend the
old articles of confederation and and
this makes it clear that you know even
after shae's rebellion even even after
these these border disputes between
maryland and virginia
it still wasn't a done deal a lot of
states still liked their autonomy like
their independence so even going into
this it wasn't like everyone was
unanimously saying hey we need to give
the federal government more power and by
the way what does that sound like sounds
like the debates we're having today
we still as a nation have always had
these debates of how much power should
be given to the central government how
much power should retain with the states
whether it's on health care or our laws
or our taxation and so it's a useful
tension to have
absolutely but then they are able to
deliver they are able to come up with a
a
a solution well it's a very difficult
problem of the big states wanting there
to be you know proportional
representation in a new congress
the small states wanting equal votes per
state you finally have ben franklin
again once again being the person who
works out the compromise to have both a
house and a senate equal votes per state
in the senate proportional
representation in the house and they
finally come together and they all agree
to line up and sign this new
constitution that will give taxation
authority to the federal government or
to congress a new congress a federal
taxation authority and by the way that
has a preamble that's a whole lot more
inspiring than that articles of
confederation thingy that said you know
to all to whom these presidents shall
come and may concern
you know let's look
let's look at the uh preamble to the
constitution
we the people of the united states so
that's as opposed to to whom it all to
whom it may concern so just look at
those first three words i mean those
first three words are totally an
inspiring thing it's never been done
before which is we the people
are getting to create this constitution
right it's not the states getting
together to do it it's not the king
devolving authority it's not a
parliament doing it it's we the people
gathered together here
we are the ones that are going to ordain
a nice religious word down there
ordained so we the people united states
do ordain and establish it's almost like
we have the power it's not coming from
the divine right of kings of god
we the people get to ordain
and establish this constitution and just
you know we've made previous videos
about the declaration of independence
you know the articles of confederation
in no way share any of the spirit or the
the poetry of the of the declaration
while
this preamble does it seems almost a
continuation of it yeah let's read it i
mean we the people of the united states
in order to form a more perfect union
now that's a very transcendent phrase
but it also means hey you know the
articles and federation we weren't
really unified we have to create a
united states we have to create a union
and in the is the more perfect is that a
direct reference to the articles that
that was a less perfect or is this is it
something else it's not a very good
piece of grammar as you know you know
things are either perfect or they're not
the notion of creating a more perfect
union yes they are making a nod to the
fact that we have been confederated
under under the articles of
confederation but we now we have to
create a more perfect union we have to
really hold together
then they decide what's the purpose of
this constitution first of all establish
justice
uh that means there'll be one common set
of laws
ensure domestic tranquility you know
this is shae's rebellion it's still
going on when they start writing this
preamble
domestic tranquility means that the
federal the central government has a
right to raise an army and that in the
end the police and defense powers are
don't reside with just the individual
states there's going to be a more
perfect union that helps ensure domestic
tranquility and provide for the common
defense because what you've had is the
continental army under washington has
been disbanded there's no way to raise
taxes for a central army now we're
saying that the union of states the
united states the federal government
they're going to raise the money and
provide for the common defense there's
another phrase promote the general
welfare when people argue about
constitutionalism and what gives the
federal government the right to do
things one of those phrases is every now
and then
we have to use the general welfare
phrase and say whether it's health care
or anything else
maybe there are things the central
government does that promote the general
welfare and then we get to the inspiring
lines you know the poetry as opposed to
to all whom these presents shall come
and that secure the blessings of liberty
to ourselves and our posterity we do
ordain and establish this constitution
of the united states of america and
we've been calling ourselves that ever
since the declaration of independence
but now it's in all caps and it's
signifying we're one nation not just 13
different states previously i think of
the u wasn't capitalized yeah in some of
the earlier documents it wasn't and we
certainly were not united it's only
under this constitution do we become
really the united states of america